no matter who you voted for i will
strive to be a vice president
like joe was to president obama loyal
honest and prepared waking up
every day thinking of you and your
family
not only is kamala harris the vice
president elect
but she's also the february 2021 vogue
cover star
exciting right but it's not without
controversy
the politicians team and a ton of people
on social media
aren't too happy about one of the images
the mag selected for the cover
on saturday harris's vote cover started
circulating online
that's the former california senator
with her arms crossed
rocking a dark suit and her trademark
converse sneakers
in front of a pink and green backdrop a
nod to her days as a member of the alpha
kappa alpha sorority at howard
university
well some people weren't feeling it with
many saying that the lighting washes her
out
and that the styling isn't worthy of the
country's first black woman to be
elected to vice president
the mag later released another pick this
time featuring harris in a powder blue
suit in front of a gold's backdrop
huffington post contributor yashar ali
was the first to report that harris's
team
thought that that pick would be the
cover adding that they were blindsided
and only found out about the switch when
the images leaked on saturday
now a source is opening up to et
explaining quote
harris's team never asked for photo
approval but the only thing agreed upon
was that the cover would be the blue
suit with gold backdrop
the two teams have been in touch
constantly throughout this process
and at no point did vogue tell harris's
team they were switching the cover
the source added that the more casual
photo was always going to be featured
inside the mag
but kamala's team never would have
approved it for the cover and is
extremely disappointed vogue responded
to the controversy in a statement
obtained by et
on monday explaining that they felt the
more informal images captured harris's
authentic approachable nature
which we feel is one of the hallmarks of
the biden harris administration
to respond to the seriousness of this
moment in history
and the role she has to play leading our
country forward
we're celebrating both images of her as
covers digitally
a source close to vogue also tells et
that the mag wanted to capture harris as
a leader
and as a person and as she was most
comfortable
adding that they collaborated closely on
all creative decisions and that both of
the looks were selected by harris and
her
team as for the casual cover image the
source says vogue selected the pic
that they felt captured her optimism
personality and authenticity
you